- [Sal] Is there a lag?
- [Producer] Okay, standby, here we go.
- Hello, I think we are up now.
So thanks for joining
our morning livestream
here at Khan Academy,
we're calling it something
of a homeroom, a national homeroom,
or an international homeroom I guess.
And every day we are trying
different types of technology,
so we're trying a new technology today,
hopefully it works out, but
definitely bear with us.
I think we've definitely
improved from earlier this week
when I was operating from
my not-so-great wifi.
But things have improved.
So thanks for joining, for those of y'all
that this is the first day you're joining
this homeroom, it's really a
way for all of us to connect.
As I'm sure many of you
know, and are experiencing,
we now have over 40
million students in America
who are now not in physical school,
they are trying to learn from home.
And we have approaching a
billion kids around the world
who are in that situation.
And over the last few, well
really over the last decade,
Khan Academy has
inadvertently building things
that can hopefully help folks navigate
this school closure situation.
This is a very suboptimal situation,
but we have over the years created things
like Khan Academy Kids for early learners,
that's for ages three through six.
Covers the head start
standards, all the way
through first grade, and
reading, writing, math,
social, emotional learning.
And I guess you could say
the main Khan Academy,
whether you're on the
website, or you're on our app,
it goes for sure all the way
in math through elementary,
middle, and high school, and even some
of the core of college.
A lot of people associate us with videos,
it's not just videos.
In fact, most of what we put resources to
are interactive exercises
that have solutions
to every problem.
Students should never be able to run out
of practice, they get feedback,
there's game mechanics
to make sure they really
mastered the concept,
there's data and reporting
for teachers or parents
if they wanna help the students progress.
We've recently launched a Beta,
which is kind of a first
draft version of our
English and language arts.
It's not quite as rich as
what we have on the math side,
but the exercise items,
I think, are quite good.
That goes from second
through eighth grade.
And then as you get into high school,
not only do we have the math, but we also
have the sciences, biology,
chemistry, physics,
economics, computer science.
For those of you in middle school,
I actually highly recommend
high school biology,
I think you have the math
background to handle it,
and it's very relevant to the world
that we're in today.
And we also have SAT practice in reading,
writing, and math, and that's
an official partnership
with the college board.
And we have all of those resources,
and we realized last week
that we've got to be able
to put these things together in a way
that it feels more structured,
in a world where so many students
are going to be working from home.
And so that's why over the past weekend
we launched the schedules on Khan Academy.
There could be links,
depending on what social media
channel you're looking
at, you could also just
do a web search.
If you just go to KhanAcademy.org,
we have banners that
lead you to the schedules
and other resources that we're having.
But that helps structure student's days.
For young students,
middle school students,
high school students,
elementary school students,
and we've been getting a lot
of good feedback from that,
and we're constantly
tweaking it so it becomes
better and better.
So please give us feedback on that.
But the purpose of this homeroom,
that was a long parenthetical,
the purpose of this
homeroom is to, as folks work
at their own time and pace,
on those types of schedules,
to feel a connectedness.
When you're in a real
school, there's a homeroom,
and there's announcements,
and we get to see each other.
We get to kind of prepare
our minds for the day.
And so this is really for everybody,
it's for students, it's for parents,
it's for teachers, just as
a way to start their day.
And in this time of social distancing,
hopefully feel a little bit connected.
A couple of announcements,
as many of y'all know,
I've been mentioning this
in the last few livestreams,
Khan Academy is a
not-for-profit, with a mission
of a free world class education
for anyone, everywhere.
Not-for-Profit means no
one owns Khan Academy,
it's a public charity.
I don't own Khan Academy, you own as much
of Khan Academy as I do.
And we are dependent on
philanthropic donations.
And we are proud, and we wanna step up
in every way possible to serve everyone
during this situation,
but what happens with
a not-for-profit like ours is our servers,
our usage has more than
doubled as of the latest data
that I saw from yesterday.
And that increases our
costs, and our funds
come from philanthropic donations
from folks like yourself.
So we definitely need help.
And so, let's see, I just,
looks like the screen just
clicked out on me.
Oh, it's back.
All right, sorry.
So we need help, but I
do wanna thank several,
there's many of y'all who've been donating
at all different levels.
I definitely wanna thank some corporations
who have stepped up in record time
over the weekend.
Bank of America was the first to step up
when they found out our situation,
and how much the resources
we have to put out there
and what we hope to do to get everyone
through this school closure situation.
And they encouraged us to think big,
so Bank of America gave
a very generous donation
over the weekend.
You can read up about that announcement,
and just this morning,
I really wanna thank
AT&T and Google.org for
following close behind
Bank of America and also
stepping up with significant
support so that we can
handle all the extra
programs we wanna do, the server costs
that have roughly doubled
now, and we were frankly
already running at a deficit before this.
'Cause you can imagine serving up content,
we have a team of over 200 folks,
and serving up content to
tens and what is likely
hundreds of millions of folks
now does take a lot of resources.
So thank you for everyone there.
So with that said, with
my asking for support
from the world, and we need more,
I'll turn to your questions.
So the first question,
and this is one we get
pretty consistently is, as a parent,
how should I figure out what my child
should be learning?
So those schedules that we put out,
they have, and you should
definitely feel free
to modify those schedules
so they work for you,
and depending on what
works for your child.
But in each of those areas, for say math,
we give some grade levels
that might be appropriate
for students of a certain age,
and I would say if your
student has historically
felt confident in math and
has done quite well in math,
you can just start them
right at grade level.
They can take something
called the course challenge
that's right from the course page,
and on that course challenge,
it'll take about 30 to 40 minutes,
they'll have to answer
about 30, 40 questions,
and then it will tell them
what they got right or wrong,
and then the things that they got wrong,
I would recommend going to
those units in the course.
And on those units, if the student feels
like they know a good bit of that unit,
they can go to the unit
test, and take that,
and then that'll give them
credit for what they know,
then they can focus on the
skills that they don't know.
And then the game mechanics
for the entire site
has unit test, course
challenges, other things,
mastery challenges, so
that it encourages kids
to show that they have mastery,
that they can fill in all
those gaps in their knowledge,
that they can do the
skills in a mixed topic
type of environment.
So that's one method.
If your child, or if you're a student,
and maybe you've felt a
little bit weak in math,
one thing that we've seen, Tim Vandenberg,
this teacher that I've been really, really
impressed by over, I've heard about him
a couple weeks ago, he actually starts
all of his sixth graders at kindergarten,
and that's not to talk down to 'em,
it's actually 'cause he has
very high expectations for them.
What happens there is, the students,
by starting at kindergarten, they're able
to build some momentum,
obviously a lot of sixth graders,
most sixth graders will get
through the kindergarten
content, they can do it
through the course challenges
in literally 30 to 40 minutes,
then they go to first grade.
You can do all of early
learning on Khan Academy,
you can do arithmetic, and he
also makes all of his students
do the third grade, because he sees that
that has a lot of
foundational things in it,
like your basic arithmetic fluency,
and your basic multiplication
fluency, things like that.
And then he has them simultaneously
working at grade level.
So I think this situation, might be,
especially if you have a
child, or you are a student
who's historically struggled in math,
I recommend spending
more time so you can work
at grade level, and make
sure that you don't have
any Swiss cheese gaps going forward.
And then the same thing is true in English
and language arts.
You should always be working at a level
that you're getting a few questions wrong,
it's a little bit difficult,
but you can definitely
engage on it, would be my best advice.
And I think over the
next few days and weeks,
because Khan Academy has
all of the grade levels,
it's a good time to try to triangulate,
where is that learning edge?
And you should be able to
get to it in about a week,
and then learn from there, and really
have strong foundations.
So let's see, Kylie Kameoka says, "Hi Sal,
"as a tutor, how do you figure out where
"the students' gaps are?"
So a very similar question.
If you really wanna go for gap finding,
you should start students
at the very basic material,
that's why we created
mechanisms on Khan Academy
to accelerate through it.
But that's really the only
way to go skill by skill
and ensure that students have no gaps.
And what we see over and over again
is even students who are A
students in middle school,
they still have a few
gaps, or they're still not
completely fluent at certain
things from arithmetic,
or the things that came before.
We see many high school
students who are not
fluent at middle school skills,
or at elementary school skills,
and so it's really valuable.
It might seem like you're
taking a step back,
but it's kind of a go slow to go fast.
If you take that week to
start from the beginning
and build up all your skills,
then when you get to
the middle school math,
or the algebra, you'll find
that you're in the right place.
If you're looking at other
topics on Khan Academy,
like biology, or physics,
I'd advocate the same thing.
Economics, take the course challenge,
understand what you
know and you don't know,
and then go back and fill in those gaps
in the appropriate units.
So Underground School says,
"Other than career preparation,
"what is the role of learning in life?"
So you know, Underground School,
it's an interesting name,
it's a deep question
of what is the purpose of life period?
And you know, I think one of the things
that makes us as human
beings fairly unique,
we know what some of them are,
we have opposable thumbs,
although all of our primate
and ape cousins have opposable thumbs.
We have large brains, and
we walk on two legs upright,
and we have language,
which is maybe a byproduct
of our large brains.
And maybe all those things come together,
the opposable thumbs, the
brain, and the language,
and I think that learning
is one of the most
fundamental human things
that makes us feel human.
And so I've gotten letters over the years
from Khan Academy, from people
who are past their career,
or well into their
career, and they realized
later in life how much joy there is
just for the sake of learning,
just trying to understand this mystery
that we find ourselves in called life,
understanding the
universe a little better.
And what I've said in
multiple livestreams is,
some students have asked,
"How do I get motivated?"
And I remind them that this content
that you can learn on Khan Academy,
that you can learn in your textbooks,
a lot of what you see in a lesson or unit
is someone's life work,
or it's probably many
of hundreds of people's life work.
And they would've done anything to see
that knowledge that you now see.
How does photosynthesis work?
What does mitochondria do?
Calculus, people like
Newton and Leibniz spent
decades trying to derive these things,
and you can now understand it
in a more distilled format.
I think that's incredibly exciting.
And it just changes your
perspective on everything,
and it also just makes
you a better citizen.
In a world where we want democracy,
we want people to be able to participate,
there's an obligation
of the person themselves
to be as informed as
possible, to be able to look
at the data that exists in the world,
to be able to think
critically about the world,
and that's what education
is gonna provide.
You'll also be more fun at dinner parties,
better dinner party conversation.
All right, Kirsten Martin says,
"How does a teacher use Khan Academy
"to teach a class at multiple levels?
"What should the teacher
component focus on?"
So Kirsten, if we weren't in
the school closure situation,
the teachers that I've
seen use Khan Academy
to great effect, and I've visited hundreds
of classrooms over the
years, and Tim Vandenberg's
the most recent that I've talked to,
I haven't visited his classroom yet.
The teachers will spend
some time with the students
that are learning at
their own time and pace
on Khan Academy, I don't
think it's a bad idea
to start all of your
students at kindergarten
and let them progress
as quickly as possible.
Or early learning in
arithmetic, and let them
progress as quickly as possible,
maybe simultaneously as
they do the grade level.
What Tim has done is he
has all the students start
at early math, but then he also assigns,
let's say they're sixth
graders or seventh graders,
he will use our assignments functionality
to assign unit one in sixth
grade, and then unit two.
And what he does is has
a double expectation
for his students.
He says, remediate, fill in those gaps
as quickly as you can,
if you don't have gaps,
it'll happen quite
quickly, and simultaneously
work on the grade level stuff,
and I expect you to be done
1/4 through the grade 1/4
through the year,
halfway through the grade
halfway through the year.
He makes his grading based on that,
but it's a mastery learning framework.
So if a student's not
quite there at the quarter
year mark, but then gets there later on,
he actually modifies
their grade to reflect
that they have now gotten to that point.
And that seems to work
really well for him.
And the way it flows in the classroom,
when class is in session,
is he's able to look
at the data of what
students are working on,
who's engaged, who's not engaged.
Obviously he can see some of that just by
looking at the classroom,
and what are students
having trouble with?
And then he can use that to take a handful
of students to do a more
focused intervention,
or maybe pair two students together
who are trying to work on the same skill,
or maybe pair a student
who's already mastered
a concept with a student who's
trying to master the concept.
And what you find is it's
a very rich classroom.
A lot of people imagine
that online learning
can be kind of this Vulcan or Borg reality
where kids are just on
computers and learning,
and in their isolated
places, but done well,
it can be highly, highly interactive.
And the teacher's able
to form good connections
with the students,
students are able to talk,
and interact, and teach each other.
And obviously, you learn things the best
when you actually have to teach it.
Now that we're in this virtual world,
I've heard of teachers and parents
emulating aspects of that where the kids
are working on Khan Academy,
and then simultaneously
you might have a Google Hangout
or a Zoom conference call,
or a Skype session at the same time
where students know that
they can go onto that
and access their peers, or
their teacher, or parent
who might be able to help them.
And you could imagine, in
this more virtual world
that we're finding ourselves in,
a parent, or a teacher,
or even an older student
could look at the dashboard still and say,
"Hey, looks like five of
y'all are really having
"trouble with negative numbers,"
and yes, the Khan Academy has resources,
and that person could
say, "Hey, make sure you
"watch the videos, make sure you look
"at the explanations on the hints,"
But they could say, "Hey, at 10 a.m.,
"I'm gonna run a 20 minute session,
"a break out session on negative numbers
"for you five to really
help you through it."
Or you might see, "Hey, Khan Academy
"does certain types of
items and problems,"
but there might be a
really rich, multi step
application problem that you can say,
"All right, half the students keep working
"on Khan Academy, but
half of y'all are ready
"for this deeper type of question,
"let's work on that together,"
and you could do it on
a Hangout or a Zoom.
So those are the types of frameworks,
but we would love to hear
from all of you teachers
how you're using it.
So Nadia Ali says, "Hi Sal, my son asks,
"what is the importance
of the points you collect?
"I answered the more points you score,
"the smarter you are, but he
wants to hear it from you."
Well I'll give a slightly
different answer,
what I would say is, the more you learn,
the richer your life will be, so that's
the number one thing to remember.
The points really are just points.
(Sal laughs)
They do help unlock things like avatars,
and things like that, but you know,
the way our brains are wired,
or many of our brains are wired,
things like points, and I
think even in adulthood,
many people are still
looking to score points
in different ways, whether you
call a bank account points,
or beyond a certain
measure, it probably is.
But you know, those are just what's known
as extrinsic motivators,
things that will hopefully
motivate you to get more engaged.
But the best motivators
are intrinsic motivators,
when you realize that the best thing to do
is just build that learning,
and maybe you could
view the points, we have energy points,
we have mastery points,
you can see your skills
that you've leveled up,
that's a way to reflect
on what you've learned.
And that's actually the
most enriching thing of all,
more than points or anything else.
But that's what the points are,
they're indicative of what you've learned.
And I wouldn't even say necessarily smart
or not smart.
There was a question earlier
about the growth mindset,
actually that's the next
question from Mahalia Lickich,
I apologize if I'm mispronouncing
your name, Mahalia,
but the whole principle of growth mindset
is there's people with
either a fixed mindset
or a growth mindset.
Fixed mindset and the domain thinks,
I'm either smart or I'm not.
And a growth mindset says,
"Well, I don't really know
"my potential unless I'm always willing
"to step out of my comfort zone,
"try things that are difficult for me,
"recognize that when I fail at something,
"that's when I'm growing the most,
"that's my opportunities for growth."
And when people have a fixed mindset,
if they think they're smart at something,
many times they don't
want to try hard things
because it might undermine
their self-perception,
and if they think they're
not smart at something,
they don't wanna try
it, 'cause they're like,
"Well I'm never gonna be good at it."
But people with a growth
mindset will always say,
"Hey, that's a challenge,
I might not succeed,
"but I'm gonna try it,
and I'll work on it."
So really the points are there to reward
and show how much effort you've put in,
and how much you've been
willing to push yourself,
and that I think is the muscle
that we all wanna build.
And if you look in the world, the people
who are disproportionately successful
are the people with growth mindsets.
The people who are always
looking to improve themselves,
push themselves, and aren't trying to say,
"I'm smart or not smart,
just I'm gonna keep seeing
"what I can do."
(Sal laughs)
So Hafsa Savilkia says,
"Anything that we can do
"as a volunteer?
"We'd love to be part of the team,
"thank you for all you do."
So there's multiple ways
you might volunteer.
We have people for languages,
people for subtitling,
I think in this time
that we find ourselves in
of the school closures,
if you're in a position,
find some kinds that you
might know in your community
that might need help,
contact some teachers,
especially kids who might
not have a lot of resources.
One try to figure out how
to get them resources,
I think computers and internet
are a lifeline right now,
not just for accessing
things like Khan Academy,
but just to be able to connect with people
now that we all have to
be socially distanced.
So if you could help someway in that,
that could be really
powerful for the world.
I think if you could
run video conferencing
tutoring sessions, classes for people
who wanna learn in your area.
We're looking at ways
that we could kind of
scale that type of thing up.
We've recommended on our schedules
that people do that, I've
already mentioned it,
teachers, parents, older students
are able to organize,
create video conferencing
places where people can go get help.
I think that could be a great
way to volunteer right now.
I think there's ways
unrelated to Khan Academy
that could be great to volunteer now.
Find people who might not
have a lot of connection
to other people, get
on Hangouts with them,
talk to them, I think people need that.
I think if there's elderly
people in your area,
offer to go buy their groceries for them,
drop it off on their porches.
I think that could be of great service.
So there's a lot of opportunity
for service right now.
But in the academic realm,
and Khan Academy realm,
I'd say right now, run
tutoring sessions for folks.
And when you do those tutoring sessions
on Hangouts, or on a zoom session,
some of it might be
explaining the concept,
but a lot of it might just be motivating.
"Hey, remember, you
could go to Khan Academy,
"that's the video.
"Hey, are you using it right?"
And they can sign you up as their coach,
so you can monitor and see how they're
able to interact.
You could say, "Hey,
so-and-so, it looks like
"you haven't been working on it,
"what's going on?"
"How can I help you?"
I think that by itself is
a huge, huge, huge service.
And we are running, I forgot to mention,
parent webinars and teacher webinars
to help parents and teachers understand
how to use our tools and our reports
a little bit more.
So stay tuned for some of that.
So I have Somol Sahu says,
"What is your typical day like?"
Well, I think that changes depending on
whether you talk about the last week,
or before the last week.
This week has been a very
interesting week, for everyone.
And I feel lucky that Khan
Academy's in a position
to help the situation.
Because as I said in other livestreams,
there's three things that
people are worried about,
their health, mental and physical health
first and foremost.
The second is the
economics of the situation,
and there's a lot of people struggling,
especially as restaurants,
and hotels, and airlines
are having to lay off folks, it's a really
tough, tough situation we're in.
But the third thing is,
there's a lot of kids
out of school, and there's a lot of adults
that are home, and are all
in the same room together.
And how do we navigate that?
And how do we make sure
that people keep learning?
So anyway, my day, yesterday
I woke up super early,
we got a bunch of press
inquiries we're leveraging
to help communicate that
these resources exist.
Then we had the livestream,
simultaneously we're
trying to still put some content out.
I have a few that are in my queue.
There's another Corona virus
video that I'd actually
like to make to help explain,
and people appreciate
that social distancing
is something to take quite seriously.
And the more seriously we do
it, and the sooner we do it,
the more likely we are
able to navigate this thing
in a very good way, and it wouldn't hurt
the economy too much.
And yeah, but right
now it's just constant,
our whole team is now virtual,
so even while I'm talking,
I've gotten four text messages
that I haven't looked at
yet, so it is just like
a bit of a war room where
we're trying to figure out
what goes on, and that day's
going pretty long right now.
In the old days, like two weeks ago,
(Sal laughs)
my day would be, I try to
split my day about a third,
a third, a third, a third
is I still create content,
I still try to make videos
or create other things.
About a third of my time
is working with the team
to help think about where
does the product go?
What features can we add?
And then another third
of my time is roughly
doing things like this,
external communications,
fundraising, talking to press, et cetera.
So yeah, that's my average day.
Okay, Galaxy Wolf Plays
says, "Will there be any
"new updates for the website and app?"
In the long run for sure, 100,
we have a whole team working on this.
Even as this crisis was unfolding,
we've actually had to
rearchitect our entire backend,
our infrastructure of
our site just so it can
continue to scale.
And obviously that's even
more of an imperative
now that our usage has more than doubled
over the last few days.
But we do have plans on
a whole host of features,
we usually launch them around
back to school time period.
But yeah, we have whole, and
there's aspirations for sure
over the next year,
two years, three years,
of the types we wanna do.
We wanna add more content, we wanna make
it easier to navigate, we eventually wanna
make easier ways, a lot of
people ask where to start?
And I've given you some ways to do it,
but we wanna make that even simpler.
So there's a ton of
things that we definitely
wanna add to the site.
Heather Sylvester says,
"My son tried to log in
"the other day and start where he left off
"in algebra one, but it's making him start
"all the way back to the beginning.
"Is there another way around it?"
Well I'm sorry to hear that.
I'm guessing, if your son
was, maybe what you're saying
is maybe he left off in algebra one
in his algebra one class.
So my advice to your son, and to you,
is he should take the course
challenge in algebra one,
and then that will give him a good sense
of what he knows and
doesn't know in algebra one.
And we do that because every course,
there's some courses
people do around the world
in roughly the same
order at the same pace,
but it's usually a little bit different.
And so, if he takes that course challenge,
he'll know where he is,
and then he can then focus
on the units where he has gaps.
The stuff that he knows, it literally
could take him a few hours to show that he
has mastery in that, and that's good,
because then he will know that material
that much better, he will have reviewed it
a few months after.
'Cause that's another issue
that a lot of kids have,
they'll go through the material
that's covered in class,
but then by the end of the year,
for sure after the end of
summer, they've forgotten it.
So this is a good chance
to review and refresh,
and algebra is one of
those foundational things,
not just for the rest of math,
but also for science, and economics,
and pretty much anything
else you're gonna do in life.
So yeah, I would say the course challenge,
use unit tests, that'll
help him accelerate,
there's also things
called mastery challenges.
Those will all help him
accelerate if he already knows
some of that material.
It'll take him a few
hours to get to a mastery
in a lot of that, and
then he'll see the areas
where he needs to work more on it,
and he should be able to
get, if he does know 60
or 70% of the material already,
he should get to 60 or
70% mastery quite quickly.
Then now he can progress from there.
And I would say, once he's
done with algebra one,
he should continue on into geometry
or algebra two, or whatever
else interests him.
So next we have David Hadimanos,
and first of all I wanna thank David,
he's one of our teacher ambassadors,
these are incredible teachers
around the country and world
who are Khan Academy super users,
and not only are super users
with their own students,
but help other teachers use Khan Academy.
So I just wanted to thank David for being
one of the ambassadors.
So he says, "Thank you
to you and your team
"for all you all do."
Thank you for thanking us.
"A couple of questions, are there plans
"to provide downloadable packets
"for teachers who need
to provide paperwork,
"and two, are there plans to extend
"upper math content further
going beyond calculus?"
So on the first one, we
don't have current plans,
but that's an interesting idea.
You're an ambassador,
so let our team know,
I'm assuming that would be for the younger
age groups that might need
more paper-type worksheets.
That's an interesting idea, and I think we
wouldn't maybe have thought
about it two weeks ago,
'cause we've always viewed ourselves
as going side-by-side
with what the traditional
paper-based curriculum is,
but in this type of reality,
it is something we should explore.
"Are there plans to extend
upper math content further
"going beyond calculus?"
So we do have video content
going beyond calculus,
multi variable differential equations,
linear algebra, we have statistics too,
which you could argue, it's not
necessarily beyond calculus.
The statistics has exercises.
So long term yes, I would
love to do it long term.
In the short term, we probably aren't.
There might be something
in multi variable,
but I can't promise that just yet.
Let's see, Bunny Hernandez says,
"We'd love to help Khan
Academy raise funds,
"how can we get in touch?"
So depending, if you'd like to donate,
KhanAcademy.org/donate,
there's also some links
I think if you're streaming in,
or if you're getting
the stream on Facebook,
we're gonna put it there,
on YouTube you might
see some donate links.
If you're looking at
fundraising in a bigger way,
helping fundraise from other people,
pop us an email at skhan@khanacademy.org,
and I'll forward it to the right person.
So it looks like we are all, oh I just saw
the screen kinda clicked out.
So it looks like we're
pretty close to time now.
So a couple of announcements.
So next week, we're going to
change the livestream time.
The livestream is going
to be at 12 noon Pacific,
3 p.m. Eastern, as of Monday.
We're gonna be doing this
livestream every week
for the foreseeable future, just to help
us feel connected during this time.
So it's going to be at 12
noon Pacific, 3 p.m. Eastern,
starting Monday, this was
based on everyone's feedback
on what would work across time zones
and things like that.
And I really look forward
to seeing you all,
y'all take care of yourselves,
stay socially distanced
but not socially distant.
Interact with your friends,
I've been interacting
with friends and family,
many of the people
I haven't talked to for a while,
but doing it on Hangouts and chats,
and things like that, and it's actually
helped everyone get through this.
And as I said at the
end of every livestream,
this is something, I remind
myself whenever it's like,
oh I'm in this house for
an awfully long time,
or whatever else, is that the whole world
is going through this.
It's a crummy situation,
but there's very few times
in history where the whole world
has gone through something like this,
and as bad as it is,
it's also an opportunity
where I think we're seeing
the good in everyone,
and everyone is trying to help everyone.
So I think we can all
appreciate that aspect
of the crisis we are in.
And once again, thank you all for joining.
This helps me feel
connected to all of you,
and thank you to everyone
who's helped out,
donated, given your
donations, we need help,
our server costs are growing very fast,
and another thanks to the corporations
that have begun to step up.
Bank of America stepped
up over the weekend,
and then today we just announced AT&T
and Google.org, and any
corporate leaders out there,
we need more help.
There's many, many students
on Khan Academy right now
who need our help to learn, and parents
and teachers who need our support.
Thank you very much.